though I guess the easy way to phrase it
is why do women hate freedom hi I'm Tim
Cavanaugh for reason TV we're here with
Alison Gibbs who's the founder and
executive director of ladies of Liberty
alliance or Lola can you tell us a
little bit that Lola well is a 501 C 3
nonprofit focusing on women in the
Liberty movement trying to build a
better community and bring more women in
as well as educate them and train them
to be leaders and either they're on
their own entrepreneurial task or
leaders within the Liberty movement how
many members do across the nation I
couldn't tell you we have a quite a bit
we have well over 4,000 what would be
some activities if I'm a young woman
looking to and you know of course that's
what I want to be only are we looking
for freedom what what would I do i call
up lola and what happens um you would
volunteer your time we have chapters all
over the country that kind of we are
very decentralized so they can do
projects on their own as well as we have
a monthly charity day where we we want
to focus charity over welfare and all
the lows together we'll we'll do a
charity effort on a charity that doesn't
take government funds as much as the
other ones probably but we also do we
have speakers at events we host our own
yearly women's caucus and pretty much to
supporting the movement and having more
women have a voice libertarians are
notorious for being dateless wonders who
fear women and you know or can always be
depended on to say something really
goofy how is the role of women in the
movement changing the way it's kind of
threefold it's women in the movement are
coming in so they're gaining a voice so
new and more and more interesting and
new perspectives are being expressed for
instance food freedom education we have
a lot of women now that women can be
serve in the military we have a lot of
conscientious objectors and a lot of
foreign policy talks as well as the drug
war it affects women secondly we are
changing the tide on the Liberty
movement because men have to compete for
the limited resources of women now that
we're bringing more women in they have
to I think it's 19 min to every one
woman so they have to kind of clean up
and be presentable and kind of
compete for the resources for that would
help across the border yeah now do you
see polyandry in the future of the
libertarian movement given the imbalance
of the genders you know what to each his
own whatever an individual chooses would
be a that's spoken like a true lover of
freedom where are you growing most and
where do you see the most women showing
the most interest the women are growing
exponentially in the younger
demographics we have our Board of
Advisors has a lot of the older women
that pretty much set the path for us and
we're finding with groups other groups
like students for liberty and young
americans for liberty or bring in a lot
of students for us that are young women
libertarianism has an interesting
pedigree in that there are three women I
grand Isabelle Patterson and rose wilder
lane who are arguably the the sort of
founders of at least a post-war
libertarian movement and yet it still
continues to be a heavily you know 19 21
male movement what is the issue i guess
the easy way to phrase it is why do
women hate freedom well women hate
freedom i I think it really is an
individual choice women for the most
part i've always been either the
girlfriends of people that are
libertarians or coming in you kind of
get shut out a little bit because you
have so many male voices speaking and
it's more focused on the economics and
other things that with some women are
very into but at the same time there are
other issues and social issues that
women for instance myself came from the
left so when the social issues i
realized i woke to liberty through
realizing that social issues were just
weren't for the left that they were also
found in libertarianism and so coming to
understand that i think is important for
women to be more open and more willing
to enter but another thing also is the
pretentious nature of libertarianism i
think that you know you can't have five
people in a room without arguing about
the semantics of one word or what the
word is means or something similar so a
lot of women just want don't feel like
they have a voice and so that's what
Lola is for it's a community a safe
place for women that where they can real
they can see other women being active
and being entrepreneurs and feel that
sense of community to empower themselves
do you think
libertarians and you know low and for
the time being let's include the Tea
Party in this discussion right now get
kind of a bad rap on this because you
can go to so you can certainly go to a
democratic event and find it heavily
dominated by white males the the whole
impetus of you know second wave 70 0
feminism was women becoming politically
active and finding that within these
movements they were still being called
upon to do housework while the men took
all the public profiles so is our is our
libertarians getting unfairly dinged on
this I don't think so I do see the
commonality between the different
parties or whatever you know magical
wonder University think that that is but
I I think that women we're seeing a
ground swell more than any other
movement were rather than the left or
the right we're seeing more women come
into the Liberty movement or
libertarianism or anarchism or whatever
you deem to call it and I think if
anything they're not getting a bad rap
because we are we are flourishing in
that nature women are hearing a voice
they're seeing that there's other women
like them out there and so they want to
propagate that and we want to be able to
create more women that so we can make
sure that's not the status quo